the leader of the solomon islands has
denied reports china plans to build a
military base in the country addressing
parliament prime minister manasseh
sagavari pushed back against claims the
solomon islands was facing any pressure
over the matter
now the solomon islands lie northeast of
australia
talk of a potential chinese naval base
surfaced after the draft of a new
security deal with china became public
and this is the clarification so govari
issued in parliament
the security treaty mr speaker is
pursued at the request of solomon
islands
government
we are not pressured we are not present
in any way by our new friends and there
is no intention whatsoever mr speaker to
ask china to build a military base in
salmon islands
goodness
we're insulted
we insulted by such unfound
unfounded stories
the story is emerging mainly out of
australia and new zealand which have
reacted with concern over a potential
chinese military presence in the region
now it's worth mentioning here that
australia and the solomons already have
a security pact between them from 2017.
so why are canberra and wellington so
concerned with a new deal between china
and the solomons i asked rory metcalf
from the australian national university
well for a long time now there has been
anxiety about the the prospect of china
establishing a military base
in the south pacific in the uh the
territory of small island states uh
between australia uh new zealand
the united states and all the other
powers of this region this
was portrayed as something of a an
overblown fear a kind of crying wolf if
you like our security agencies for about
four or five years now have been warning
that something like this would happen
and of course now it appears that with
this security agreement between the
solomon islands government and china the
door is open for a chinese military
presence in the solomon solomon islands
not immediately a fully fledged base but
the option to lodge military and police
forces there to protect chinese
interests and perhaps to uh to do other
things as well
now solomon's island's uh prime minister
manasseh
as a sovereign nation the islands could
determine whom it wanted to partner for
its security interests with i mean
that's that's like a reasonable argument
isn't it
look that's absolutely right i mean
every country has the uh the sovereign
ability to choose whether it wants to
have
a foreign military power putting forces
uh on its soil the concern that
countries like australia and new zealand
have here is that this is firstly very
contentious within the solomon islands
it's uh it's divided between uh the
government and the opposition which
strongly opposes
the china military connection and also
there's a big question mark over the
origin of this deal there have been
allegations in the past of chinese
influence campaigns uh perhaps even
bribery to strengthen china's position
in the solomon islands it was only a few
years ago that the solomons did
basically a big switch from recognition
of taiwan to recognition of the people's
republic of china and the accusation
there was that a lot of money changed
hands in that process so yes there's a
sovereign right there's a sovereign
choice
but the question that is being asked is
is this in the best interests of small
island states whose security concerns
are much more closely developed i'm
sorry are much more closely connected to
issues of
development the environment health
fisheries human security rather than
having a foreign military power on this
soil
you talked about this switch to of the
diplomatic recognition from taiwan to
china and then now you have the security
deal coming along what is behind this
shift to china that we're seeing
there's a much bigger dynamic at work
here
in my view and i think the view of many
analysts china is on a kind of
quasi-colonial
push to
extend its power and influence across
this maritime region
that's been the subject of my own book
the so-called belton road the maritime
silk road the extension of influence
through investment and infrastructure
and technology on the one hand that may
be a good thing for local development if
there are infrastructure needs but on
the other hand it's quite clear that the
chinese state is using these methods to
extend its influence
over a wide range of small countries so
that in turn
it can in time project security and
military power it really is a kind of
empire by stealth and the concern for a
country like australia
is that if you like we are being
out flanked in our own
neighborhood in our own region a chinese
military force in the solomon islands
would essentially
block the way between australia and its
ally the united states
rory metcalf we leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us today
you